又上课了啊。
这个得有半个月没没没没录新课了吧。
一直没更新，为啥呢？
给他发了一个特别大的痘，心情特别不好，好为痘消了，但留了个痘印儿还。
那没办法，不能耽误上课呀。
咱们开始上这个课的时候呢，因为是个网课，我老说最就网课最不好的地方是啥？你知道吗？没有反馈。
就我现场没有学生，我现在对着空气在讲，只有一个学生，对吧？我模拟以为有很多人还要经常看个这看看那儿。哎哎对啊，模拟一下。
就说这一点我特别不适应，因为没有反馈，你没有办法从学生。
那个求知的脸上看到渴望，看到疑惑，对吧？看到兴奋，你没办法得到这些反馈，对你的讲课啊节奏把控。
确实有伤害，而且你有时候就会错过一些重点。
因为我完全是用啥在讲课，你知道吗？我完全是用共情在讲课，就我我以假装我是个学生，我不懂写剧本，我不会，然后我去揣摩，我想知道什么，这样的话就会出现问题，就我有时候共情没有那么到位，我以为你们肯定会的地方，我一对而过了。
然后我以为你们哎呀肯定特别想知道的地方，我在那嗷嗷讲，你们心里想哎呀呀，赶紧讲下边吧，对吧？这就是现场没有呃。
没有同学，我就会单单用共情呢，我会犯这些错误。所以请大家多包涵，多原谅啊。
咱们但是好在是网课，你可以快进嘛。
你可以重点的课程多看几遍，不想看的课，或者已经学会的课，你就跳过。还有人跟我说什么。
1.5倍速看我的课，你们是有多瞧不起人是吧？我的信息量干货就。
就那么少吗？还1.5倍速什么？好吧，我也是通过学生，我才知道现在我看片有1.5倍速，我活了这么多年，我都不知道网络视频可以1.5岁播1.55倍速的播放，我真不知道。
我都是在那个那个那个咱的学生群里知道了啊。对，好在咱现在有有这个学习交流的群，有几个微信群，还有QQ群。
这个这个在群里啊就可以一定程度上解决这个问题了。
我可以在群里看到我。
我们的这个这个学员，同学们有些什么样的疑惑，有些什么样的诉求。虽然它是延迟反应吧，但是我我还是可以看到的。所以这节课呢我打算给大家呃查漏补缺一下，解答一些我最近发现的普遍性的问题，普遍性的问题。
嗯嗯嗯。
先解个先解决一个小问题啊先解决一个小问题。
就是我们的同学啊。
大部分现在都是一个很好的一个学习状态。
就是哎呀求之若渴，而且也取得了一些成绩了。
我收了。
得有一两百份作业了，我都我都没有时间完看完。
就是大家在进步，也在努力。
但是呢。
这个这个这个总有总有个别同学会出现一种。
你说他是杠精吧，也不是，他有时候也是好意，或者是一种习惯。
就是比如说什么啊，你跟他说。
哎呀这个。
一场戏最好是动作进动作出，让你的剧情流动起来，然后他就说不一定吧，老师。
有的戏他就是状态进，状态出的呀，比如说那什么什么什么什么。
然后我说这个电影需要流动起来。
他就说不一定吧，老师，你看那个有个电影叫智个男人来自地球，从头到尾在一个房间里叨 me叨叨 me叨不也挺好看吗？
对吧。
然后我说哎呀，这个如果是双男主，这两个男主最好是互补的，或者是一个球面的两端，对吧？可以。
互相帮助，互相弥补。然后他就说不一定吧，老师阿呆和阿瓜两个傻瓜呀，你说一般一个傻，一个聪明，一个那个那个风骚，一个淳朴，对吧？一个外向，一个呃内内向，那两个都是傻子呀。
啊吧。
其是然后他就希望我能解答他这样的问题。
你说这种问题咋解答？
这种问题没有必要解答。
那说明啥呢？说明这个同学还没有进入学习的状态。
他还没有进入学习的一个状态。
他没有进入一个吸收知识。
的一个11个状态。
就像你啥就像你跟他说什么，你知道吗？就像你说哎呀。
吸烟有害健康，他肯定也会回答你，不一定吧，老师，我有个舅姥爷，一天两包烟活到了93。
你说这个问题你还有必要回答他吗？
没有必要回答他，对吧？你说你想证明什么，你就问他，那你说你舅老爷这个事儿，你想证明什么呢？
然后他就说那。
我就想哎，反正你说的不对，嗯，他就是没有进入一个学习的状态，他还是在一个抬杠的状态。
这个这个学习这个东西啊。
我们必须先去学习规律性的东西。
我反复强调啊，你必须先去学习规律性的东西，你才能在这个基础上发展你的个性。
先学技术再发展艺术。
你说我作为一个。
老编剧。
作为一个从业这么多年的一个编剧。
你觉得我会不知道这个男人来斯击球这个电影吗？
对不对？
我活了快40年了，你你以为我没有见过90多岁的老头叼着烟的吗？
我没有见过吗？
我当然知道。
但这不代表。
不影响我们去总结规律，明白这个意思吗？
我这么说吧。
我不是之前打过比方吗？
我说学编剧啊。
你就假装他是因为他是个手艺，他是个匠人。
你假装他是在学设计汽车，我有没有打过这个比方，设计汽车嘛？就设计汽车的。
咱们是一个汽车设计师，然后我现在是你们的老师，我教你们规律，对吧？我说呢一般一个这个这个汽车呢设计，我们先搞一个底盘。
然后在底盘上弄一个发动机，但是我们先得琢磨好我们是前驱还是后驱，前置后驱，还是四驱，对吧？弄上了以后呢，在上面再装上四个轮，车驱动传动系统，变速箱，再弄上四个轮，然后弄上这个这个搭个车架子，四个门，五个座。
对吧按一个方向盘。
我在讲着讲着，就老有同学跳出来，不一定吧，老师有的车它不是四个门啊。
对吧？然后我说对对对，也有两个门了。他说不一定吧，老师有的车他只有一个门啊。
对吧有些赛车他为了减重一个门一个座嘛。
然后我说对对对，也有一个门了。他说不一定吗？老师还有一款跑车，它没有门啊。
对，真有一款跑车没有门。
还得得卖进去，而且只能敞棚，没有盖，有没有没有？
我说那你想证明什么呢？
对吧。
就我们先学规律性的东西。
我我教你们设计一辆汽车，那我们就先按照那它到底是烧油还是电动，对吧？现在主流的你要么烧油，要么。
呃，这个这个烧电，然后他非得出来说，老师还有这个锋利的，还有烧烧那个酒精的。
这个你去网上查有有那样的，确实有我承认有，那怎么样呢？我还可以告诉你，不光有烧酒精的，还有车既不烧酒精，也不烧油声控的。
你信不信你说嫁他就往前走，你说鱼他就刹车。
能证明什么呢？对不对？所以就是这个东西啊，我跟你说为什么会有这种情况啊？
我我其实明白为什么会有这种情况，就是因为这个这个。
咱们国家的基础教育啊没有逻辑学。
如果有逻辑学。
就不会出现这种情况了。
因为逻辑学在很多教育体系里面，很多国家的教育体系里面，它是门基础课程。那在基础教育的时候，你就应该学。但是在咱们国家呢好像只有本科才开始学逻辑学导论，而且就学个导论，我也就学过导论。我后来是自己又看别的很对这个逻辑学感兴趣，才又看别的书。
咱们国家这个教育啊就学点捣论，而且好像也就是大一一门。
也不怎么直学分的公开课，俩俩分吧，两分的一个课。
所以整体来说，大家是没有逻辑能力的。
所以你才会出现一种，你说吸烟有害健康，马上跳出来好几个人跟你说，我有个舅导爷一天两包烟活到93。
然后他也不知道自己想证明什么，你也不知道如何跟他辩论。
在这种情况下就不要辩论，因为辩论的基础建立在两个人都有基本的逻辑能力和世界观。
在这个基础上，两个人才能辩论。
你要是聊这个，那就没法聊。
对不对？
那咱这个课也没法上，你如果脑子里面全在想这些事情。
那我就是说这种同学呢他就还没有进入学习的状态。
没有进入学习的状态。
我们编剧这个课呀，我说为什么有时候。
难学。
就是因为。
就像教你设计汽车一样。
我们的学生全都开过车，你知道吗？他们都自以为自己见多识广，就我教你写剧本。我们虽然大家没有写过，但每个人都看过很多影视剧，所以他就永远感觉自己。
可以说出点特例。
你跟他说，哎呀，在这里需要一种什么样的一个规律性的东西？
这么说吧。
我们先把基础打好。
你先给我做出一个。
四门5座的三厢轿车。
你等熟练的能做出。
这样的车了。
你再去弄一个。
火箭我都不管你。
是不是你去造火箭，造穿天猴，我都不管你。
我只教你量产车。
至于发展艺术，我可以启发你，我可以给你方向，给你思路。
我也不拦着你。
但是你现在先把基础打好。
你去看呀，这这个这个。
奔驰宝马奥迪主流的车型，宝马3、宝马5、宝马7、奥迪A4A6A8。
都是四个门，五个座儿，四个轱辘，对吧？我告诉你来来，同学们先给我按下四个轱辘，马上就有杠筋跳出来。老师有三个轮人的。
脏崩子。
对吧？
有我知道还有斜跨也是三个轮。那。
能怎样呢？对不对？
等等你真的加入一个三崩子公司的时候，你再去学三崩子的设计原理也不迟。
他有专门的一套自己的体系。
也不迟，我们先把基础打好。
当然你将来从我这儿出去能加入一个牛逼的三帮子公司，我也祝你成功，是不是不要抬杠？
所以就是。
这个问题为什么说这么长时间啊？是因为在群里经常我看到学生在那争吵这个事情。
两方哗就吵起来了，马上就这边就就引战话题，你知道吗？就跳出来一个同学说啊，这个吸烟对健康无害，然后咔这边就吵起来了，对吧？或者是啊男主不需要那个什么什么，你看有个什么样的特例，对吧？我就姥爷。
老师举举他舅老爷的例子，然后双方就吵起来，我就说这种问题不要争论，他没有必要，他对你学习没有帮助，因为他不是学习状态而的争论。
好吧，这这这这这个话题就说到这儿啊，全是废话全是废话那个那个。
哎呀，进入学习状态的同学根本不需要听这一段话，对吧？他们不会出问题的。
太热了啊，这这这这这个天儿。
来。
我们说。
频频最近频频提到的第二个问题，就我这个学习群里我看到的第二个问题。
因为大家一直在做作业嘛。
我也收到很多作业上的反馈。
就很多同学说呀。
自从听完十序列就原地踏步到现在。
220天了，听完时序练原地踏步到现在。
我说为啥呢？咋的了？
他们说你说从1序的开始就是事件群，用事儿说话。
我说那样。
没写呀，把你的大纲什么的系列搞成事儿啊。
他说呢什么事儿呢？事在哪呢？
就向我提出了这个终极问题。
我一想也是确实我共情不到位，我没有体会到同学们会就我没有料到同学们会卡在这儿。
但是提出来之后我是理解了，我就想想啊，确实也是没有事儿。
这个问题咋解决？你说这个问题咋解决？
这个问题最终真正的解决。
要靠。
小本儿。
要靠素材。
要靠常年的积累。
常年的积累，我为什么让大家去拿小本记素材？
我说一方面记你看过的那些好片子里面给你的触动，那些素材，你那些你经历不到的人生，经历不到的生活，你从片子里面去体会去共琴。记下来。
还有一。
我说你真实生活中你的观察，对吧？
你你你给你有感动的地方。
给你哎一侧梦易回头的那个瞬间，是什么触动了你？
你也把它记下来，捕捉一各种小细节。
捕捉各种素材。
我就说那你就是靠技素材。
来增加你对事情的敏感度，你的储备，你的触类旁东。
我说这是最终的解决方案。
但是同学们这卡在这儿。
着急。
我也着急。
然后有同学就就就就。
就又问说那老师那个。
斯奈德的节拍器。
会对这件事情有帮助吗？
因为咱们讲过时序列嘛。
我当时其实暗示过，我说十0个序列啊也是一家之说。
有人分成15个序列是吧？当我说的那个15个序列，其实就是指的斯奈德接拍器。
你说能不能有所帮助啊？
能。
他毕竟把10个又分成15个，下放了一集，又细了一点，对吧？
有所能有所帮助。但是我之前为啥没讲呢？我怕把大家诓死。
因为你越分的越细，相当于越束服了。
分的越细就相当于越束服了。
比如说他这个设计图过于细，然后就让你照着这个设计。比如我说这个车必须都是前驱，因为你看家用车大部分是前驱，对吧？然后我就说这不是的，都是前驱，我怕你们以后就真的就不会坐四驱车了，明白吗？
就是我不想过早的框死你们。
所以那个序列。
关于序列，我并没有狠狠的细讲。
一细讲一举例子，我怕。
大家就全部。
一样的。
这也是那个旧猫咪这套这个教材，斯耐德先生这个节拍器啊，为什么呃在在在在在在教育界呃在在这个主流教育圈，大家谨慎推荐了一个原因，一般都是推荐。
职业编剧去看。
就是你已经学会了，你有自己的体系了，你不怕被。
呃，被误导就相当于啥呢？就是假设就是他是丰田家的一个设计师。
你作为一个呃已经成型的设计师，你上他那去参观去学习，没有问题的。
你肯定会有收获。
学到东西，但是你也不会被他带跑偏了，完全诓死，对吧？就他也是一家之说，但是同学都强烈要求我讲一讲，所以我在这里声明一下。
我可以给大家讲。
没有问题，我今天把他这个节拍器都打印出来，我可以给大家捋一遍讲一讲。
但是我还是这么说，斯耐德先生是非常好的剧本教育家，他这个理论帮助了许多许多人。
嗯，但是初学者谨慎使用，他可以帮你提供思路，但你千万不要被完全的框死。
不要被完全的com死，好吧，所以这节课我们就讲一下斯奈德。
节拍器。
也叫节拍表，好吧，15个节拍。
我们先从我们的。
之前讲过的序列里面。
回忆开启这个这个节拍表。因为我说了啊，10个序列跟15个序列，它只是就是。
切刀的地方不太一样而已，其本质上是相同的。
我们说咱们那个那一套东西叫什么来着？，我们这节课做横轴吧，好吧。
一个横轴。
我们说之前咱们咱们分的时候。
是分四段，对吧？
我们说叫启程转合呀。
起程转合对吧？我们说思募式，然后我还说等分嘛。
100分钟的电影是2525、25。
四等分。
对不对？
我们说。
四等分儿。
四等分。
其实就是。
打5个点，记得吧。
我们说这里是开场。
对吧。
这里是激励。
然后。
这里是那个叫什么？
转折对吧？
这里是什么？
危机。
啊，这里是。
高潮。
记得吗？十个序列，然后我们说这是这个这个打5个风向标事件，五个风向标事件。
还要再补5个。
类似于。
朝梁型的呃事件。
其实就是叫切入进展。
这些词其实都差不多啊，这里叫再转，对吧？
这里叫导入。
然后我们说高潮之后再再赠送一个什么？
再赠送一个结局，其实就是给个结果，给个说法。
给观众一个i放情绪的。
是这个这个这个安放情绪的一个一个寄托。我们说你看这是不是就是我们说的实序列？
这是不是就是咱们之前说的时序列？
之前咱们说的时序点。
有些同学卡在这儿。
说。
让我们用节拍表，咱们用节拍表啊，咱们用节拍节拍表的方式。
重新强化一下对这个事件序列的理解。
斯戴德先生。
认为起程转合。
是。
他按照110分钟分的。
110分钟。
也就是加10分钟，它加在哪了呢？加在乘和转上了。
加在成客转上了，我们在这给大加一加，这个区别不大啊，这个区别不大。因为电影少的他妈有90多分钟的多的有3个多钟头的都有，是不是？所以这个。
他只加了这么一点，就说明他还在商业片的这套呃叙事理论里面没有大的变化。只是他认为肚子可以更胖一点。
就肚子可以更胖一点，那我们就按照他这个时间啊，25、303025，总共也就是110了，变成110了。
为什么把分钟数专门明确出来呢？因为斯耐德先生呃这个这个就是斯耐德接拍表嘛，他对分钟数是卡的很死的。所以我说他特死板，就特别要求必须比如说他激励必须从12分钟开始，12，你知道吗？十三不行吗？对吧？我觉得也是行的，但如果咱们再上。
思老师的课的时候，你就不要抬杠，你就好好听人家怎么说嘛，是不是？咱们这些这咱们今天就假装思老师在这儿，咱们听他怎么说，对不对？咱们就就听人家说说能怎么的。
好，那咱们就来看它是这是1，对吧？这是10个嘛，这是咱们的这个时序点，对吧？
这个司老师是15151115个打点吧，他叫节拍嘛，他叫节拍嘛，我们就就就就15个大点。
好。
他有个他首先有一个叫开场画面。
开场画面。
他用的是。
前两分钟。
前两分钟是开场画面，这里是在这儿好吧。
我背部下来啊。
然后前十分钟。
他认为他管这叫。
铺店。
其实也就是切入。
就在切入这个位置有个铺垫，然后。
在这里。
他认为第5分钟的时候要点一下主题。
点主题。
是第5分钟。
就是另另外一个时间，就前25分钟啊，他要办这么多事儿。
就第5分钟的时候，他要点一下主题。
然后呢，12分钟就是我说的那个12分钟。
12分钟。
他这里叫什么呢？
他这里他12分钟，他叫推动。
就他他开始从12分钟开始推动推动这个故事了，就是开始推着往前走了，其实就是激励。12分钟，你推着主角要动了，那不就是激励吗？
然后12到25。
12到25，我们把25这个出现拉下来啊，12到25是争执。
是12到25。
那这就是前25分钟。
前两分钟开场画面。
第5分钟把主题点点出来。
点点出来第10分钟呃，就是1到10分钟，这里应该是啊1到10分钟。
整个都是铺垫。
12分钟。
开始推动就开始推动，它这种叫推动。
然后12到25增止。
整个也就是。
前25分钟的。
几的阶段就是有开场，有切入，有激励，只不过他把切入。
叫做铺垫。
他把激励分成了先推再争值，因为为啥？因为激励以后关这个这个主角肯定要所进行所谓的争执嘛，我不可能一激你。
你就办大事了呀，我激励我举过什么样的例子，哇我看到一个姑娘好漂亮啊，太好看了，我要得到她，对吧？然后你最后的动作不是迷奸她吗？你不可能一看到哇，姑娘好漂亮啊，我就去迷奸她呀，你总得先争执争执嘛。
对吧甚至还得先追求一下吧，依次动作先搞一搞嘛。
这就是所谓的争执，好吧。
我每一个都讲一下吧，我共情一下同学们，我感觉好像同学们对这些干巴拉的概念。
听不懂吧？
我每个都讲一下啊。
开场画面是什么？
我之前说过啊，每一场戏你具体到场的时候，每一场戏都是要传达信息的。
都是有具体的作用的。
开场画面这一场戏传达什么信息？
基本上啊传达这么几个重要的信息，一个是影片的基调。
就这是个什么片，就让观众看出来了。
这是个鬼片。
阴森森的气氛你就要搞起来了。
对吧这如果是个枪战片，那种哇这个这个这这个这个这种呃人吃人吃人的社会，或者这种西部的荒凉，这种感觉就要搞起来了。这如果是个枪战片开场画面，它一定是高楼大厦呀。
明白吗？你不可能说我这是一个商战片儿，但是我因为这个我的这个呃男主角，他在商场在这个商业领域很有钱，所以他在乡下买了个别墅。我的开场画面呢是乡下他那个别墅的小花园不行。
你的整个片子的气质是华尔街之狼，是商业大战，那你开场就得是高楼大厦。
各种啊那个人来人往，西装人拎着公文包熙熙攘攘那个。
这就叫开场画面。
啊，不是瞎来的。所以开场画面是讲这个呃是奠定这个片子的基调。
大概的这个气质。
你知道吧？是勾勒你片子气质的。
嗯，也能传达出你这个片子的类型啊。
他是个警匪片，还是个什么什个个西部荒凉的感觉，还是那个商业的，还是浪漫的爱情，类型也能传达出来。
细致情绪基本上就是传达这几样东西。
开场画面。
如果你还有闲心，开场画面可以顺便把时间地点也传达。
这是个现代的故事，还是1个90年代的故事，还是一个民国的故事。你开场画面能做到这个吧。
对吧地点也能传达出来，这是一个北方的大森林音。
下雪还是一个南方的流水小镇。
对吧还是呃外国还是哪儿？
时间地点。
也搞出来。
就两分钟的事儿，前两分钟的事儿。
把这个。
开场画面搞出来。
然后1到10分钟。
铺垫。
铺垫啥玩意儿？
前十分钟啊，其实就前十分钟铺垫啥玩意儿？
我们那个。
我们启程转合是用的中国中国话。
我们那个那个那个之前那个这里叫什么来着？起，这里叫什么来？叫建制。
那个词儿在这里就比较适用建制。
建立。
设置的意思。
铺垫就是干这个了建立和设置这个世件。
其实这个铺垫是干一个世界观的事儿。
人物主题世界观。
前十分钟搞出来。
搞出来。
斯外德先生说的更极端，说你这个角色这个电影中出现的所有的主要人物，在前十分钟必须露遍。
这是斯戴德先生说的啊。
我也没那么说。
呃，这节课咱们啊不对不对，这节课咱们就假装在听孙老师了，前两课必须出。
思老师说的出就得出，你走出这个门儿，等你在学别的的，等你加入三帮子公司的时候，你再按三个三帮子设计。思老师说，前十分钟所有的人物必须出，咱们先假装他是对的。
铺垫人物。
主题世界观全部都搞出来。
全部得搞出来，就是啥叫呃。
世界观啊啥叫世界观啊？就是说你营造一个啥样的世界，你在前十分钟要干出来了。